hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to you
know I was walking down the aisles of
the video store when I noticed something
I haven't seen in years
cartoon all-stars to the rescue
immediately a pool of disappointing
memories came flooding back to me and I
just knew I had to see this piece of
shit again now for those of you who
don't remember the special I'll give you
the skinny usually some clips from the
special would play here but seeing how
my copy died a long time ago I'm just
gonna move on without it
Oh critic yeah what are you doing isn't
it great I'm recreating the glory days
on my first review but you're missing
one of the most important elements it's
only half a review without it no it's
okay I've thought about that you see I
fill in the void by replacing it with a
bunch of other critics like black Critic
little kid print animated kidding critic
sexy female critic invisible critic who
might just be a wall and of course cameo
critic yeah it's a living was this a fan
request or something
no that's the great thing about it
nobody wanted to see it and now it's
here for everybody to witness Creek how
can anyone enjoy a recreation that only
is half of what made it good forceful
comedic sidekicks practically nothing
new to offer and wasn't something that
the fan base ever demanded in the first
place that I didn't they get the idea
all right
Blues Brothers 2000
based on the classic SNL Chicago musical
about two blues musicians trying to save
an orphanage and somehow end up becoming
the most wanted men in America
the sequel shot 18 years later is kind
of like that - the enjoyment it's a
desperate retread between writer actor
dan Aykroyd and writer director John
Landis to relive the glory days by
somehow bringing us none of the glory
and such it's said to be one of the most
pointless underwhelming and just
downright bizarre sequels in comedy
history and trust to me that's saying a
great deal so let's see what's wrong
with the past by getting out of the past
this is Blues Brothers 2000 at first the
opening number seems legitimately subtle
and even kind of atmospheric but this
movie is like Huntington's disease it
works very slowly
good morning warden John Frank Oz plays
one of the many returning cast members
who just looks old and sad now and he
tells Elwood about his brother Jake's
departure you got no part you got no
comedy you don't even have the other
blues brother unless you have an
entertaining sock puppet under your head
count me the fuck out of this so what
you're finding out about his drug
overdose in prison a friend of a friend
pops by to pick him up a mere twenty
four hours later hey better late than
ever
all right you'll constantly say in this
movie better never than ever matera you
dropped me off here please so I trust by
the numb from the previous installment
to tell you who else died since the
first time you saw Curtis has gone on as
well
Elwood I'm sorry the orphanage is gone
Jake's gone Curtis is gone
I got no brother I got no roots I got
the life I got nothing for Christ's sake
and yet you're still making a movie see
the problem here by the way isn't it
good to know that the orphanages go on
to that everything the first film was
working for was completely in vain he
was very upset when the orphanage closed
maybe that whole intro where God was
giving light to Jake was actually
supposed to be saying
no no actually I was aiming for the
person in the front row yes that person
I demand you to put Nicolas Cage and a
Left Behind believe fair thigh will and
totally confusing ways are done you to
pop you just get a shitty sequel good
boy
bullshit but it's okay because they
bring in the obvious target audience
this movie was meant for young Buster
here is awarded the state the
archdiocese has agreed to house homeless
children here I thought perhaps that you
would come and spend time with buster
yes because nothing makes more sense
than teaming up an innocent youth with a
convicted felon who literally just got
done serving 20 years of jail bullshit
something else you'll notice is that
while Aykroyd Chicago accent in the
original was playfully exaggerated this
accent sounds like it's coming from a
fucking Muppet it's a Kabul I think you
need a hug who wants to know what folks
she's bone dry a part of this band's
repertoire what's that got to do with me
hey hot dogs the Bears pizza the head to
make Jon Stewart accept defeat
oh yeah we're still right in that but
the kid is not so easy to get rid of I
know what you're going through you're
lonely searching for your place in life
just don't blow it like I did besides
you don't want to hang around with some
over 40 recidivist you don't even even
need it for this review the movie does
quite well pointing out all the problems
itself he discovers that Curtis had a
son played by Joe Morton who apparently
has no idea that Curtis was his father
yahwah talks about reuniting the band
but his kind of brother doesn't take it
very well don't come back here again
got no plot you got no comedy you don't
even have the other blues brother unless
you have a role for me in terminator 12
count me the fuck out of this but the
kid steals the commanders wallets giving
them just enough money to buy a new
Bluesmobile now i want you to remember
this moment where he steals the wallet
i'm not gonna explain why yet but just
keep in the back of your brain elbow
goes to the club his old band member
owens we're up look at that clearly we
see a new
into the blues brother oh not because
you've played by John Goodman not
because he can sing the blues not
because they've made countless
appearances together years before but
because of the astounding chemistry and
unforgettable character traits that this
movie gives him that dare I say it even
rival that of Belushi watch this hi and
there you go that's all the character
you need folks don't believe me well
they top it with even more incredible
character traits like there's this yeah
what you got the keys to the trunk the
unbelievable this please meet you
and of course who can forget the classic
line so what's the plan got that is so
whatever his character's name is it
doesn't matter if they barely look each
other in the face or hardly ever have a
conversation
the magic is there yeah they have more
chemistry than Hal 9000 and Stephen
Hawking hey he'll pick two one two you
will now have to imagine I am poking you
in the eyes causing a humorous effect
nuke nuke but it turns out the club is
being shut down by Illinois Russians
yeah that's right Illinois Russian god
that doesn't have nearly the same Flair
as Illinois Nazis
yeah
Jesus Christ you're making soda pop
Pinsky looks like an equal rights leader
so they're not the Russians out and
leave them in an alleyway somehow
thinking this won't lead to any more
trouble but lo and behold the Russians
come back for vengeance yes they break
out the club while the Russians burn it
down only to find the Russians were
waiting to chase it Wow apparently those
nails are so powerful they launched them
several feet behind where they
originally started seriously how the
hell did they get back in front of the
club again was there a special company
that made those nails Oh
so I Kroy did Goodman set out to pick up
the rest of their band members when no
dub dub dub dub dub you killed the movie
you kill the movie whatever little speck
of chance you had to make this
entertaining it was assassinated the
minute you put that kid in a suit this
is like giving Wolverine a puppy or
Jules Winnfield a Martian or the
Terminator oh yeah that happened these
are unsophisticated men the only things
they respond to our fear in the draw of
look Melissa this by using iconographic
symbols and psychological intimidation
okay I'm really amazed you're saying all
this stuff about intimidation while
including the ten-year-old kid in your
argument
the only things they respond to our fear
in the draw look we have a ten-year-old
kid iconographic symbols and
psychological intimidation with a
ten-year-old kid presents a uniform
image of strength and organization with
a ten-year-old kid don't say anything
look me with the ten-year-old do you not
see what a castration this is to your
film boys I'd like you to meet my new
partner in the act mighty Mac we've just
been calling them Jake number two I'm
getting the band back together
man you can't talk about this stuff here
Matt she's back from lunch but sure
enough they're working again for an
Aretha Franklin cameo and once again
they had to argue their way out of it
while she blindly goes into a song you
treat me with respect at all times I do
baby and you know
what I mean you know we're the first
movie was kind of funny and how out of
nowhere and unexpected the transition
was in this one
you obviously know it's coming you even
know what song is going to be any of the
transition is still sloppy as fucking
shit it's almost like somebody hit the
screen accidentally changing the channel
no there's no surprise to it anymore
we know they're just gonna join the band
like last time so all we have is a
slower less energized version of the
scene we saw in the first flick this is
like watching grandma say she can still
strut her stuff and you shutting your
eyes as she disturbingly tries to swing
her hips in a sexy fashion just serve
the potatoes already grandma Matt this
is something that I really don't want
you to do ah for crying out loud and
this is what you're gonna be like to
live with go ahead I mean Jesus you got
no plot you got no comedy you don't even
have the other blues brother unless you
have a well-paying Pepsi commercial all
for me cut me the fuck out of this they
give back the other members of the band
who again demonstrates some killer
acting chops hey fellas I think I know
that voice Steve you know I think that
sounded a lot like Elwood J blues no
place to run and no place to hide
oh I'm sorry with that paint drying I
confuse the two on levels of engagement
and they finally have to get their last
member back from his old job
we need Murph on the keyboards I see I
told him I wouldn't go without your
say-so just what is it that you do
exactly and if you can sing about it
even though we just had a goddamn
musical number a minute ago Debbie motel
why do these musical numbers annoy me so
much more in this film than they did in
the last one they're not bad they're
good renditions done by talented people
even Macaulay Culkin seems to get a solo
but there's just no damn spacing between
them they just go from one song that has
nothing to do with anything to another
song that has nothing to do with
anything the music in the original
didn't have much connection to the story
either but at least there was a
homicidal fiancee car chases funny Cod's
fucking Illinois Nazis that's enough to
fill in the gaps what do we have to fill
in the gaps in this one I haven't played
a County Fair since 68 sounds like a lot
of laughs didn't you used to be Elwood
blues yeah
salt we're rehearsing just on the other
side of the motel office it would be so
cool if you could come listen to his
play sure sure fuck me with tuna we just
got done with a song are we really gonna
do three in a row
even water boarders give their victims a
break every once in a while let's ha ha
oh look at that
our characters so don't care how the
song works into the movie that they
don't even stick around to hear up the
movie itself is that not interested in
its own musical numbers why don't we
just have the rest of the movie be a
runaway letter from Dan Aykroyd saying
you know guys I just don't care I might
do a little singing here there and maybe
my cartoon character Chicago accent but
frankly I don't give a shit
dinners in the freezer tell your mom I
love her damn on top of that the musical
numbers were in between a spiritual
quest a very bizarre Redemption
involving putting the band back together
too earnestly and honestly raise money
to protect their childhood home that's
one of the reasons there's so much
urgency for the band members to leave
their dead-end crappy jobs and do what's
right in this one have you noticed
something missing something kind of a
big deal
there is no reason to put the band back
together
none at all they all have good jobs that
pay well
let evil rekindled old romances that
seem to be working out pretty well
why the fuck would any of them leave
this behind there is nothing to fight
for nothing to chase nothing to gain
Redemption they're stressing the
importance of putting the band back
together even though they forgot to
mention what was fuckin important about
it
in the first film the phrase was we're
on a mission from God we're on a mission
from God on a mission from God now in
this one the phrases the Lord works in
mysterious ways the Lord works in
mysterious way the Lord works in
mysterious ways
kept so mysterious that you took 18
years to work on a sequel that somehow
you forgot to give a reason for even
fucking existing it's kind of important
for a film to have a reason to fucking
exist especially when it's a sequel to
something is goddamn awesome as the
Blues Brothers fucking I need a break
here's the only thing certain after
death taxes and everything you love
either getting a shitty sequel or a
shitty remake commercials
you
tired of a movie giving you an
unbelievable experience only two fine
years later the same filmmakers fuck it
up with their shitty sequel or spin-off
will fear no more because we've invented
fuck it all now you can stop caring
about a movie series you once loved by
acknowledging it probably wasn't that
important to begin with can you believe
the person who directed a lien did this
sure it makes no sense and pales in
comparison to the original whatever hey
if I didn't know any better I'd say you
didn't think this was a big deal I don't
it's only a movie what I used to be
emotionally invested in what I watched
but now the more I think about it maybe
Joseph gordon-levitt should play rob
know maybe the Hobbit did need all those
extra scenes you're insane
maybe mythical ourian's aren't such a
bad idea
wake up damn it don't go where I can't
bow with a heavy enough dose you'll
forget all about Sophia Coppola in
Godfather emo Peter and spider-man and
all pretentious dialogue from the Matrix
movies gonna fuck it all
because it doesn't matter if while The
Blues Brothers is a little kid or John
Goodman or plotless or has a car that
can do anything because you know who
cares who cares at all that it's a
timeless classic the original yeah who
cares who we just want to fuck it up I
mean we just want to totally destroy it
because you know it's just the Blues
Brothers that doesn't matter that it's a
Chicago icon it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter at all excuse me can we
call 911 or something no no I want to
get this on my bag I'll get this off my
back The Blues Brothers is just this big
symbol of Chicago and it's funny and
it's creative and it's musical and it's
fantastic and when they tried to just
half-ass it like this ancient come with
me let me show you something
this is Hollywood Boulevard theater it's
a good place you can get alcohol while
watching your movies which you'll
definitely need for this film but you
know it's what's on top of there the
Bluesmobile and not just Bluesmobile a
statue of one of the Blues Brothers dan
Aykroyd
they put a fucking car on top of a movie
theater you wanna know why because the
movie means that much to him
it means that much to Chicago it's an
incredible film so that the music at the
action the comedies I'm writing it's so
fucking unbelievable and for you but for
you after they made a goddamn statue out
of you Dan Aykroyd just make this insult
this fuckin insult to this goddamn
classic masterpiece I'm sorry it's
despicable
hey it's fuckin despicable that's what
the Blues Brothers means that's what
they're all about it for this movie
tonight even tried it not fuckin tried
to acknowledge what the hell they are
what the hell they meant it's just a
bullshit I'm just going back to sing
with fuckin wrong with it
apparently something resembling a plot
tries to rear its ugly head in the
second half and sister Conan O'Brien Tom
Brokaw the secretary from Ferris
Bueller's Day Off informed the holy
mother that they think Elwood has
kidnapped the boy of course rather than
just explain he's not kidnapping him so
the more I think about it maybe he kind
of fucking is they instead have to stay
to get away out of a diner filled with
cops ah of course the old look like a
minion from Mario too which will cause
the police to do nothing for some reason
allowing you to go into your car and
spin around for a solid minute or three
also causing the police to do nothing
for some reason and then take off
driving ingenious but it's okay because
they brought in more people on this case
once that don't just stare blindly at
tricks that wouldn't fool a kindergarten
class I have every lawman in two states
on this border let him just try
through this roadblock I do hope my
pompous declaration of righteousness is
by no means comedic Aliyah foiled but
hey if the Blues Brothers I'm sure they
have some awesome driving skills that
result in a kick-ass chase scene or this
bullshit
um you sure Elwood isn't in a coma and
these aren't just the dreams he was
having in the coma not that the film
isn't tragic enough for how much pain is
causing but at least we would know
somebody's suffering for it they come
across I don't know
Indiana Nazis well of course foil their
plans of being Indiana Nazis by
apparently lifting their boat of
explosives out of the water and quite
literally watch it just jump up into the
air by no discernable rhyme or reason
funny neither do I so they find a way to
sneak into their next gig a hidden
Elwood tells them to find a place to
park stop stop stop
I'm sorry I have to check for my own
clarification if they really cared so
little let's go back again they sneak
into a gig Elwood tells them to find a
place to park and is there anything
fucking anything that shows how they
randomly got in a flaming car spinning
on a loop
right this film has been edited for your
viewing confusion hell the advertising
for this movie should just be tired of
the world making sense Blues Brothers
2000 and everybody would say yeah
humanity did lose its fuckin mind in it
of course they start playing their next
song to the audience's delight when all
that won some mighty heard of red ical
she's so good hopefully God has come to
destroy this movie before it gets any
worse
my god
you know I was gonna ask when did they
stop making a Blues Brothers movie but I
don't think that question would be
appropriate I think the real question is
when did they ever start making a Blues
Brothers movie what the hell is this
it's not Blues Brothers
maybe it's fucking clay nation's Blues
Brothers but it's not the Blues Brothers
weaker off with this is just dumb random
and fucking dumb it's like suddenly
going
those pony rider though pony rider his
plaintiff I stole rich tragic cuz he
never knew friendship was magic
no fucking credit critic Rick wait
didn't you do this joke before look I
don't know the scientific explanation
for it but for some reason every single
time somebody says pony on the air Ned
the views go through the roof they do
yeah what pony pony so it starts raining
which of course somehow doesn't affect
any of their equipment and Elwood uses
his remote-control car yeah because the
Bluesmobile was made by fucking Batman I
guess and helps them escape the team
however has very low morale due to the
fact that they have no goddamn idea what
the hell they're supposed to be doing in
this movie hey Elwood I think we got a
rebellion on our hands
why what do you mean you got no quad you
got no comedy and you don't even have
the other blues brother unless you're
willing with split stock on crystal head
vodka count us the fuck out of this fine
bye Elwood himself starts to feel a
little down but the kid comes in for
almost one minute of inspiration yellow
blues I know one said the no
pharmaceutical product could ever equal
the rush you get when the band had sex
mmm again I'm gonna ask you to remember
this scene I'm gonna bring it all
together in the end that seems to work
and they happen to come across an old
friend in a tent Church played by James
Brown this whole film is like a mix
between a sad high school reunion and an
old folks home it's like the worst of
both worlds those men are criminals and
they're under arrest
the commander comes in about to arrest
them but just like before somebody's
about to see the light now in the
original a light shines on Jake in a
comedic ly over-the-top way well if that
was over-the-top
this is pole-vaulting over the fucking
moon
falling of the blood
chris is my
you know I'm just gonna try something
here
I'm sure you've all played this game
before cards against humanity' they have
an online version if you haven't you
should it is fun bring the kids
I am so convinced that this movie is so
bad shit insane and so doesn't care what
the hell they put on screen that I'm
just going to choose three random cards
and see if that randomness that totally
out there randomness matches up with the
rest of the shit that this movie gives
us so let's see a one hundred and thirty
year old voodoo witch zombies rednecks
being turned into rats you know I'm
gonna give this movie the benefit of the
doubt I don't even believe that this
film with all its batshit craziness they
did it didn't they she's a hundred and
thirty year old voodoo witch
what are you doing no seriously what the
fuck are you doing I don't get it I
really don't none of this adds up in the
least it's like you're trying to piss
off the people who love the first film
so much why no really why are you trying
to piss us off what are you trying to
atone for something are you trying to
tie it back to a mistake you made in the
past what if there's something you
fucked up before and you're trying to
somehow make things right by making this
goddamn stupid god I think that I just
figured it out
the crazy scenarios semantical crap
having nothing to do with the original
the fact that doesn't make any goddamn
sense whatsoever I got it I finally got
it they were trying to make a
live-action version of the video game
think about it every hip movie needs a
game and clearly the game and nothing to
do with the original so they were trying
to tie them together so that they
wouldn't have to make another game
you
you guys are fucking morons not only
does it make for a bad game but it makes
for an even worse film as once they
appease the 130 year old voodoo witch
god I its cannon and gets themselves
into the band along with the commander
by the way the cops still come to try
and take them away I guess it's time to
say goodbye they think he kidnapped but
they're wrong it would be hard to
convince them of that well if I go back
with them don't put me in some foster
home with people who don't love me and
I'll never see you again and we'll both
be sad forever okay this is what I was
getting to before remember why I told
you to remember that one scene I was
only a few seconds long of the kid
stealing the wallet and remember I told
you to remember that other scene where
the kid motivates Elwood and I was only
over a minute long well those two scenes
are actually more important than you
think I know you thought they were just
pointless little scenes one only being a
few seconds long and one only being over
a minute I mean how long is the movie
two hours what big difference can that
make but actually it makes a huge
difference a huge fucking difference
happy whoa no why because those two
short little scenes as despicably short
as they are are literally literally the
only things the kid has done throughout
the entire film oh sure he dances a bit
wears a suit even plays a harmonica but
in terms of contributing to anything
else I need like anything in the story
any kind of character traits any kind of
personality nada not a thing he barely
even says a word throughout the entire
film or looks Elwood in the eye a
two-hour movie and he has a minute and a
half of worth so at this big scene where
you're supposed to want to see them
together it literally makes absolutely
no sense what so ever this completely
ridiculous visual - The Blues Brothers
story was entirely pointless pretty
fucking amazing
the Lord does work in mysterious ways
Elwood yep bullshit
put on your seatbelt the only thing we
can hope is that all that wasted time
all that lack of character
all those lazy jokes at least have been
sacrificed for one hell of an epic
climax you're fucking kidding me you're
goddamn fucking kidding me
that was the end of the movie that was
the end of the movie to that did you see
the first film that you apparently made
that it did you even take a glance at it
before you made this piece if you don't
recall how the first film ended I'll
give you a little reminder it had and
and and and and and and
and you have put on your seat book
movie I'm not angry yes I am I'm furious
but there's something I'm even more and
that's disappointed and disappointed in
your movie same people that brought us a
comedy classic an icon something they
make statues of has 18 years to put
together a follow-up and this is what we
get
may God rape you with a pickup truck
slowly with vengeance
I'm serious people it's bad it's really
really really bad as a standalone movie
it would make no sense as a sequel it
makes even less sense it is absolutely
one of the worst follow-ups to a classic
ever and if you're wondering if there's
anything about you even the smallest
tiniest teeny-weeny is little victim to
the soundtracks method I mean that too
for all its problems every single singer
in this movie even our leads sing some
really good surprisingly impressive
renditions of timeless classics it's
strangely kind of impressive hell I
might actually pick it up after removing
this film's cock from my anus but aside
from that this is not only one of the
most pointless sequels ever made it's
one of the worst it's one of the worst
because talented people the same who
made a fantastic hilarious unique
musical classics so obviously phoned in
this half-assed reunion just so they can
all sings of karaoke together it's a
straight-up insult to the first film and
I can assure you these statues you see
of the Blues Brothers don't exist for
this piece of shit they exist for
something smarter funnier and just
around better and the fact that this is
connected to it I
I need my fuck it all
I'm then dystocia critic and hopefully a
few minutes I won't remember who I am
Jason shit
bullshit